I’m gonna be honest okay
please don't tell the new age feminist this
but I would 100% rather stay home,
cook and clean
100% rather do that okay
I love to cook and I love to clean and organize
Shh feminists shh, I know okay
But I love to cook good food and I love to clean and I love to do it for my man
truly I do, however,
if that's expected outside of marriage
hard pass that actually sounds like you're taking care of a child
but the look on a man's face
when you cook for him,
clean for him,
do anything to please him,
that's what it's all about.
watching him admire you with his blissfully happy eyes
it just, it melts your heart
There’s just something in me as a woman
that makes me feel like this whole traditional/wife living isn't such a terrible thing
why did we actually want to work?
what was the idea or perspective of pursuing a career?
there’s nothing more satisfying than having a man that takes care of you
A true gentlemen
that provides for you,
you don't have to worry about anything
if you do that,
I'll cook and clean all day!
why would I complain?
I'll make you an incredible five course meal if it means I can stay at home
what did we fight for again as woman,
because I'd much rather be exhausted from cooking and cleaning for my family
than be exhausted as career driven woman working a job I don't like
You can hate me all you want,
but I'd 100% rather stay home and be provided for by my man
and take care of him in return